au plus haut niveau c'est un impact sur
la santé puisque celle et ceux qui sont
les plus exposés c'est à dire à cerner
par exemple on a les habitants qui
vivent vraiment dans la vallée au coeur
des veaux donc ils sont exposés en
permanence mais on entend aussi très
bien même quand on est un peu au dessus
et bien donc là il ya aussi des
questions de qualité de vie bien sûr sa
prose est aussi quand même des questions
de sécurité parce que souvent les
niveaux sonores élevés sont quand même
associée à des fortes vitesse là on en
est plutôt à discuter d'une part avec
les services du département pour mettre
en place des aménagements pour
contraindre les les gens à respecter les
limites de vitesse
et puis aussi des discussions avec les
gendarmes et les services de l'état pour
pour renforcer les contrôles